If I want to roar all the ridiculous things, in Japanese, I only need to write a simple sentence.
This sentence will continue to grow longer, grow longer, and grow longer: until we throw a "Chinese character bomb" like a ninja in a writing system,
But I have not figured it out yet
The things that make Japanese characters cross the top make them really embarrassing.
Don't forget, you can't forget that Japan borrowed Chinese characters from China.
This is important because it explains what happened next. When a Chinese character crosses the sea by boat,
It takes its own Chinese pronunciation, but Chinese and Japanese are
Two very different languages, the pronunciation system is different. So every Chinese character is not pronounced like the Chinese say.
But pronounce it like the Japanese heard it.
Let us imagine this history. "Hello, who are you?"
"Han (han)." "Hey, look (kan)." "No, it is Han (han). "Yes, look (kan). Nice to meet you, see (kan)."
This is the top of the Sapporo ice sculpture.
What makes this confusing cultural mismatch better is that it happened a long time ago.
The exchange of sounds, this is the way Chinese characters from ancient China sounded to the ancient Japanese.
As I explained last time, most of the Chinese characters are like a bad dumb game.
Some Chinese characters tell you this "sounds like"
In Japanese, the confusion from this phonetic voice game blurs "sounds like"
Fantasy shows that the pronunciation of the mixed culture of Chinese characters is Chinese and Japanese.
read. In Japanese, people call this "sound reading", which literally means "sound reading" if you use
If you read the Chinese pronunciation of a Chinese character, there will be more than one way to go.
Understand "sound reading." We continue, this is the 5th century Chinese character Wu Yin
Then there is "kan'on", which is the Tang Yin from the 7th century.
The pronunciation of "tou'on" was later transmitted to Japan.
The final "sound reading" is "kan'you-on", after a few centuries, irrelevant or even wrong pronunciation
It became a regular correct pronunciation. So, yes, don’t do the “sound reading” you are learning.
In fact, there are a lot of Chinese and Japanese pronunciations surprised.
This has interesting consequences. If you go to some Zen ceremonies, they will recite some
The heart of the script written in Chinese ancient Chinese. But here is Japan, and these are all Chinese characters.
So how do you think the scripture is pronounced? Use ancient Chinese? No. Use standard Chinese? No.
In Japanese? Nor is it! They are just a series of "sound readings".
Basically it leads to gibberish in both languages.
Chinese characters can be more than just "sound reading" or even "training"! As I said before, Japanese and
Chinese is a very different language, which means that all borrowed audio readings have passed through one century after another.
Also a foreign vocabulary. But you thought
Is the Japanese local vocabulary set aside to make room for the sparkling new Chinese phrases?
No, the Chinese characters that come over must also adapt to Japanese. So at that time Japanese words were matched with Chinese characters.
It looks very appropriate.
This is the Chinese character of "truck" or "big car", it has some sound reading,
The basic one is "sha", but there is already a word in Japanese: "kuruma". So this word can
Represents any pronunciation above.
This is really unscientific, just like you can have a variety of Chinese pronunciations.
When reading a Chinese character, why not have a variety of Japanese language training?
There are even more trainings to join. Self introduction,
This is to have a proper name, and it is usually another Japanese native pronunciation of Chinese characters.
The moment of excitement is not over yet, friend!
Because it is time to forget the pleasure of reading and think about the fun of writing.
This is a system that really makes you crazy...
I mean, um... really amazing... this is a Chinese character!
If you want to play faster, lose the meaning and history of Chinese characters,
You can get some borrowing words that are only used for pronunciation.
When you see "sushi" like this, this is just a loan, not these words.
Have the meaning of this word.
Sometimes, according to the logic of Chinese characters, Japan will build its own Chinese characters.
Just put together the words! Because you will become rich because of this dumb game.
These words are called "national characters."
Sometimes, there are some updated or older methods to write the same Chinese character.
I want to believe it! I'm dying!
Sometimes, a Chinese character is too complicated, or you just think that you are creative, you need
Simplify it in some way. By simplifying, I mean, completely transform it into not recognized by the public.
But I will sit and look for something like "What is that? It is not in my
On the official Chinese character list." Simplified!
And proficient in a Chinese character is just a small part of "battle." Chinese characters often don’t have like you
The meaning that is considered, or that they do not represent some meaning as they are.
Japanese likes to combine a few Chinese characters to say a word. Walk you, Japan! Despite stacking up the words!
If you are still comfortable with the Chinese language, go further and grab those simple three-character idioms.
Or a four-character idiom, these idioms usually use very short syllables
To express the meaning of esoteric.
No!
I assure you that this is not the whole thing out of control. did you see it?
This is not the strange syllable that was said last time, not when you start reading, training, borrowing words,
Simplify the abbreviations to memorize the dilemma of Chinese characters.
This is when you first put the ink into the seemingly regular
The paper looks up when the beast comes up. Ok,
Think about how intricate these Chinese characters are, they have small horizontal lines.
There is a pen, and...--when I am serious enough to tell you that there is a correct, wrong
Write when writing each stroke.
You did it, but next time, I need you to help me.
Stick to our channel